[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hello, everybody.
Welcome back to the Data
Science Hangout hope everyone's
having a great week.
If we haven't had a chance to
meet yet before, I'm Rachael,
and I lead our pro
community at Posit.
So, the Data Science
Hangout is our open space
to chat about data science,
the leadership, questions
you're facing, and getting
to hear about what's
going on in the world of data
across different industries.
And so it happens every Thursday
at the same time, same place.
So if you are in the
future on YouTube
and watching this
recording, just
know that we'd love to
have you join us live too,
and you can view
the link to add it
to your calendar
in the comments.
But together, we're
all dedicated to making
this a welcoming
environment for everybody.
And so we want to
hear from everyone
at the Hangouts no matter
your level of experience
or area of work.
And so it's totally OK if
you just want to listen in.
Maybe you're eating lunch
or going for a walk.
But there's always
three ways you
can jump in and ask questions
or provide your own perspective
on topics too.
So, you could jump in by
raising your hand on Zoom.
You can put questions
in the Zoom chat,
and you can put a
little star next to it
if you want me to
read it instead,
or else I'll just call on
you to add some context
and introduce yourself.
And then lastly, we also
have our Slido links
where you can ask
questions anonymously.
And so our team will share
that in the chat here
in just a second too.
But thank you all so
much for being here
today, and thank you so
much, Josh, for joining.
I feel like I've wanted you to
join us here for a long time,
and I'm so excited to
have you here today.
Josh King is director of
marketing, data science,
and analytics at
the Knot Worldwide.
And Josh, maybe to
get us going, it'd
be great to have you introduce
yourself and your role and also
something you like to
do outside of work.
Sure.
Sounds good.
And sorry that it's taken so
long for me to actually land
on the show.
I feel like we've been playing
a game of cat and mouse
throughout that.
No need to apologize.
I think was-- since,
like, Domino's maybe.
I don't know.
Yeah, it's been
Domino's, which
was a couple of years ago.
So yeah, I'm the director
of marketing data
science and analytics,
or, easier to say,
DSNA, or another way is
saying marketing science.
So, I've been with
the Knot Worldwide
for about seven months,
but it kind of really
feels like it's
going on seven years
with just the pace that
we move and the amount
of cross-departmental
collaboration we have.
So, we have a specific
marketing focus in our group
that's pretty new to the team,
and the team is pretty small
right now because of that.
So, we have three analysts on
my team, one data scientist.
I'm also hiring for
another data scientists.
So, if you're in the
market definitely
feel free to reach out.
So, there's one position on
my team focusing on marketing.
We have another
senior data scientist
that's focused on
operations based out
of our Barcelona office.
Mine can be remote
anywhere in the US.
We also have a
product data science
manager that we have open and
also director of data science--
basically my counterpart
but in operations
that's also based out of Spain.
So we have a lot of
open roles right now.
Feel free to reach out
to chat about those.
And so my team at TKWW has
an embedded nature, and we
partner really
closely with everybody
who rolls up to our CMO.
And this is across the
entirety of the world.
So we don't just
have like a US focus.
We're a global
company, and we have
a global purview within
marketing data science, which
is pretty nice.
So, prior to coming to TKWW--
some people
internally call it TK
Dub Dub, which is even
shorter and easier to say.
Prior to coming here,
I had about a year
at a series E startup
called Policygenius,
where I was basically
doing the same function.
That was a lot of fun-- very
fast moving, smaller company.
And then prior to that, I had
about four years of experience
doing a very similar
thing at Domino's.
So it's very different going
from trying to sell pizza
to trying to work in
the business of love,
which is pretty nice.
So, one thing I like to
do outside of work-- so,
I love hanging out with my wife.
She's also very close
into the R community.
She used to use SPSS for
a lot of her analysis.
She's an academic.
She's a professor at Duke,
and I got her to transition
over to R.
Now she jokes around that
she has a self-rated package
that she calls helper whenever
she needs my to help debug some
of her code, which is
pretty nice for her
to have me as an
asset like that.
I also have two kids--
five-year-old son, almost
11-month-old daughter-- and I
love to play hockey
outside of work.
So, I play hockey one night
a week in an adult league.
Big fan of the Carolina
Hurricanes if anybody else here
is in the Southeast.
And yes, Louis, I think
my kids will use R.
My son already
says that he wants
to be a data scientist at
five, which is pretty awesome.
I love it.
That's awesome.
Well, thank you.
Thank you, again,
Josh, for joining us.
I was putting on LinkedIn that
I have been on a lot of the Knot
websites in the past few
weeks because I have eight
weddings this year coming up.
So, I was just curious.
Could you share an
example of a project
that your team is
working on or maybe
how you use data at [? Knot? ?]
Yeah, so we have a pretty
robust data infrastructure
within the company.
So, I'd say like a year
ago, our data function
was set up in terms of pillars
to have data competencies
really be the pillars.
So, we had a data science
pillar and an analytics pillar
and a data engineering pillar.
And we had a new
head of data start
up with the company
about 10 months ago,
and he had identified that
there were some organizations
within the company
that didn't really
have a lot of the strategic
partnership within data.
So he set it up to have more
of a business competency focus
in terms of pillars,
which a lot of brands
are doing these days as well.
So now, there's, rather than
based on data competencies,
more focus on business.
So we have myself as the head
of our marketing data science
and analytics function.
We also have a head of product
data science and analytics,
head of operations
that we're hiring for,
and then also a data
platform, which is basically
all of our data engineers.
So, there's a pretty robust
gamut of data problems
that we're working on.
I think for marketing
specifically, as I referenced,
marketing didn't really
have a significant amount
of historical embeddedness in
terms of data science maybe.
There was an analyst
that would support them,
but not really in data science.
So, a lot of the models that
were working on building out
right now are
pretty foundational,
at least from my perspective,
to work with marketing.
So we're currently focused
on building out a media mix
model, which I know
a couple of weeks
ago, there was a significant
amount of discussion
in here kind of about that
and my interest in that model.
And that model is
really focused on using
a lot of disparate data sources
across all of our marketing
channels, to give marketing some
good insight into an optimal
spend amount across
all of our channels,
to drive the most
acquisitions as possible
in the most efficient
means that we can.
So that's one aspect.
The data scientist that
I'm hiring for right
now is going to be focused a lot
on driving some more engagement
and solving our
lifetime value problems.
So I think some
companies-- like,
especially if you consider
back to Domino's, where
if you want to drive
an increase in lifetime
value of your customers,
then it's like, how do you
get them to purchase once a week
when they were once a month?
Or how do you get them to
increase more of their pizzas
within the orders
that they're making?
But within the Knot,
in our global brands
there is a pretty
discrete amount of time
that somebody is actually
considered our customer
because they join our--
they come to our platform,
and they become a customer
probably somewhere
around the time they're
getting engaged.
And then by the time they
get to their wedding,
they're basically
no longer really,
like, revenue relevant
for us anymore unless they
get-- they're doing
something like thank
you notes after the fact.
So we have a pretty discrete
amount of time for somebody
to get engaged.
So, how do we identify the value
that we can get out of a couple
as soon as we acquire them and
getting them to engage along
the appropriate manner?
So it's going to be pretty
cross-functional working with--
not just within marketing to
try to drive, like, acquisition
of high value customers
but also considering,
within product, how can
we do some A/B testing
to drive higher LTV couples
into a more relevant experience
and drive a lot of
personalization?
Something I just
figured out yesterday
was the partnership with
certain hotels on the websites.
Like, you can see
who else is going
to that wedding is going to
be staying at certain hotels.
And I didn't know
if that's, like,
another way of
driving revenue too.
Yeah, so we do have--
in terms of our revenue streams,
there are a few different ones.
And when a couple
comes into our platform
and they become a member, they
can create a wedding website.
And the website itself
doesn't inherently
drive any value for us.
That's almost like a free
offering that we offer.
But then if you consider,
like, attaching a registry
and then talking through the
commissions that are built off
of that one or
something like that,
start to get into some of them.
And then a lot of it is
our primary business model
we're focused on is on the
overall wedding experience
and helping couples
do what it is
they need to do to plan that
huge moment in your life.
So that could be what types
of paper do you need to buy,
which is like, invites, save
the dates, thank you cards,
et cetera, or building
out a registry.
Or the harder challenge is
when you're planning a wedding,
there's a lot of different
vendors and venues
you need to work
with in order to just
have your wedding go smoothly.
So we are a dual
sided marketplace
where couples can come into
our platform and search
for vendors that are
local to their area based
on their budget levels and
what they're looking for.
But then also, we're
working closely
with the vendors themselves
to have that aspect about,
here's how you can market
within our platform
and consider getting just in
the eyes of the couples who
are looking for you.
And so that aspect of being
a dual sided marketplace
from a data perspective allows
for a lot of fun challenges,
because we're not
just a B2C company.
We're also a B2B company.
So we have a lot of
different challenges
to try to approach
that from both angles.
It's really interesting.
I'm seeing a few anonymous
questions coming in,
and one was do you notice
a change in your work
during wedding season.
So, spring to fall.
Yeah, so if wedding season is
spring to fall, generally our--
like, the height of
our traffic as people
are coming through our
website are generally
going to be before that one.
So, that's probably
when we'll start
seeing a little bit of a
lessening in terms of people
that are coming into the site
and actually engaging with it.
So, I think engagement season
is generally considered
around January or February.
So we have a significant
influx of membership
during those times.
And then most people
are in the, like,
8 to 14 month engagement
period, we found.
So, as you start
getting through,
you can kind of consider the
different journeys that people
are going on based on not
only just the time since they
registered but also the time
since they're getting married.
And that kind of
allows a good means
of personalization in
terms of sending people
on the appropriate
journey that's relevant
for them based on both of those
different event dates that
are happening.
I see, Katherine, you put
a question into the chat.
Do you want to jump in?
KATHERINE GERTON:
Yeah, I was curious
as to what your
analytics of-- you
know, speaking of wedding
season, the lack of wedding
season during the last
several years due to COVID.
And I said speaking
of someone who
had to postpone my
own wedding twice
during that time, what did
that look like for you guys
from like a data analytics
and marketing perspective?
Yeah, that's a great question.
So, I wasn't here at the time.
So I'm speaking somewhat
second hand only
about what I've
heard through this.
And a lot-- and it definitely
changed our seasonal patterns
in terms of when
people were coming in,
especially early
on in the pandemic,
when people weren't necessarily
actively planning out
weddings because they
didn't know if they would
be able to have a hosted
wedding with all their loved
ones actually live
in a room somewhere.
So that made it a bit
of a challenge in terms
of couples coming into it.
But we did see a lot
of pushed out planning.
Kind of to your
point, like, if you're
getting delayed or
postponed, then you
may need to have a longer
cycle that you're actually
considering.
One of the benefits is
that weddings-- and this
is generally called, like,
the industry of love.
Like, we're all about
celebrating these big moments
in your life.
It's fairly recession-proof,
which is a pretty good thing,
where there's always people
that are getting married.
And even if it's smaller,
where they may not necessarily
be spending as much, whether
that is due to a session
or due to the
pandemic, we do still
see a significant amount of
couples using our platform
to help plan out the
best event for them.
Marlene, I see your
hand is raised too
if you want to jump in.
Sure, hi.
Hey, Josh.
Thanks for joining us today.
Yeah, of course.
You brought up having a
limited span or a limited time
to engage with
the client, right?
Has there ever been
discussion about kind
of expanding beyond the
wedding season, right?
Because I think of it as
the main functionality is
to stay engaged with the group
of your circle of friends
and family or whatnot,
just relevant people
that you want to keep
in the loop, right?
And there's other
milestones that you'd want
to keep them in the loop on.
It could be children.
It could be graduations.
It could be huge promotions
or moving out of the country,
right?
So, are there thoughts
about maybe the Knot kind
of expanding to
something like the Stork,
right, where now you're
announcing baby stuff, and--
I don't know.
Those were just thoughts that--
how to expand your
client longevity, right?
Yeah, that's a great question.
So I think generally, when
I'm thinking about it,
and it's just how the company
is, like, our biggest market is
in the wedding industry.
So, that's primary focus just
because the global wedding
industry on an annual
basis is $250 billion.
So, it's a pretty significant
market availability there.
But we do-- so,
within our brand,
we do have many different
companies across the world
in 16 different
countries but not
just focus on
wedding, especially
when you consider
in the US, we also
have sister companies that
are part of our global domain
for the Bump and the Bash.
So the Bump, to your
point, is kind of
focused on that
next iteration that
may be coming after you have
your wedding, which is focused
on being a new parent.
Like, what do you
need to know, and what
are the different things
you need to plan for there?
And the bash is more
focused on, like, just
general celebration--
like, having
some event planners or some
party planners or some party
venues to celebrate any
of those big moments
that you may be considering.
I think a lot of the focus
is put on the former, which
is more on the wedding
side, just because that
is a very significant industry.
But it was interesting.
I've been recruiting
for this position
that I'm hiring for
for a couple of weeks.
I was talking to a
candidate the other day.
And actually, I was
talking to one yesterday
who said she's going to
be on the call today.
So if you're here, hey, again.
So, I was talking to a
candidate a couple of weeks ago.
Actually may have been
the same candidate, now
that I'm thinking about it.
And she brought up this aspect
of after somebody gets married,
maybe a year from
now, just send them
an email to say, hey,
it's your anniversary.
Congratulations.
And I think just,
like, a general email
like that when
somebody is our couple,
it may not necessarily
drive any revenue from us.
But it drives a lot in terms
of just customer mentality
and having us as on the
forefront of their heads
that go and talk to their
friends and families
about the services that we
can provide and what we are.
Oh, Trupti.
Hello.
She's here.
I see.
Somebody had asked
earlier in Slido,
is your team solely
R focused, or do you
have more of a mixed code base?
Yeah, we're very
mixed right now.
We have-- I think a lot of our
production code is living in R,
and a majority of the
analytics that are happening
are in R. We do have a fair
amount that's also in Python.
That's one of the reasons that
I really like the reframing
from RStudio Deposit.
It's kind of like it's
just all inclusive.
You can focus on
anything you want.
I think if you're focused on
what language you're using,
you're less focused on
the business problem
that you're trying to solve.
So I definitely like
the reframing there.
But yeah, we do have a specific
amount of codebase built out
in both of them.
I think you asked a question
a little bit earlier.
Do you want to jump in?
And I can start reading
the question too,
but it was going back to the
mixed media model, I think.
So, there could be various media
mix objectives, such as reach,
frequency, or awareness.
I'm not sure if I framed that
the right way as the question.
So, Lewis, feel free to jump in.
LOUIS BOGUCHWAL: Yeah,
I guess just asking,
are those objectives
your team thinks about,
is that kind of what
you mean when you're
doing media mix modeling?
Or is it something
different entirely?
It's definitely not
different, and that's
something we're thinking of.
I think generally
in terms of the MMM,
this is a project that I kicked
off with a data scientist
that I hired back in November.
So we're still pretty
early on building out
our initial proof of
concept for a single outcome
variable for a single brand.
I think as we continue
to expand on this one
and get a lot more
iterative and bring out
a bigger scale to a global model
and also on different outcome
variables, definitely
awareness is
one that's top of mind for us.
So we have a significant
amount of marketing
spend right now that's focused
on really capturing user
intent-- that they're
already in the market,
and they're searching
for something that's
very relevant to our company.
But considering a
lot more how do we
start scaling to
truly drive awareness
across those engaged or
pre-engaged couples who
will be engaged soon so that
we're already top of mind
when they get to that stage
rather than after the fact
and find us after.
It's pretty significant
benefit in the US
that the Knot has really
strong brand awareness already.
But it definitely
could be better.
Wedding Wire, our
other brand in the US,
is still strong but not
quite as strong as that Knot.
So it's definitely
one of the things
we're always considering.
Something I know
we were talking
about a little bit earlier in
preparing for this week is you
talked a little bit about
how you drive and stir
empirical thinking with
your teams and marketing
stakeholders.
And I remember googling, like,
what that actually meant.
And now I don't remember.
So, can you tell me a
little bit about that?
Yeah, so I was working--
so when I was working at
Domino's-- this was probably
back in 2018--
I went to this conference called
ARF for Advertising Research
Foundation, and it's
just a conference
for people that work in
advertising and marketing
space, whether that's
advertisers themselves or brand
marketers or data scientists,
to get together to kind of talk
through best practices.
And the keynote in that
conference, the speaker
said, I want you all to
take away one thing today,
and that's to go back to
your workplace and foment
empiricism.
And at the time, I didn't really
understand what that meant.
And then as I continued to kind
of sit on that a little bit
and let it marinate, I
really thought about it and--
because generally, foment has
a very negative connotation,
which is kind of like, I'm
going to stir up and cause
some trouble.
But if you consider
fomenting empiricism,
it's like, within whatever
workplace you're in
or whatever setting
you're in, just driving
the thinking of having
data and empirical evidence
to support your decision
making, I think it really
goes a long way for, as
I'm talking to my team
or talking to our
business stakeholders,
to think through we may have
a gut feeling about something,
but how can we think a little
more analytically minded
and try to challenge ourselves
to see what the data would show
us and try to drive a bit
more value in terms of what's
capable there rather than
kind of just taking things
status quo?
I'm guessing that's what
you're referring to.
Yes, that is.
But I'm curious if
there's like a time that
comes to mind that your team
did that or project where
that helped the outcome.
Yeah, I think generally,
it's more of a mentality
that I try to push with my team,
especially as we get requests
from stakeholders.
So, one thing is I try to
push an embedded nature,
especially within
the Analytics team.
The data scientist team are
more focused on like a project
basis.
The analysts are really
embedded within the teams
that we're working with.
So this could range from brand
media, social media, content,
SEO, CRM, performance marketing.
We work with a lot of different
marketing departments.
And the analysts are
basically aligned
to some of these
different aspects
to really be embedded within
those cultures and not just
an outsider kind of
looking in to try
to get context after the fact
when they have a question.
So, as they're
embedded, it allows
for us to think as a team rather
than say, hey, I'm a marketer.
Hey, data team.
I have this problem.
Can you solve it for me?
It's more this is a problem
that we have as a company.
Now, how can we think
together to better ideate
this overall business problem?
So, the analysts
really have a seat
at the table to have
a lot of the ideation
to identify that we even
have a business problem
to begin with, and then
take that business problem
and translate it now
ourselves as the data team
into a data problem
and then build a data
solution to solve that problem.
But I think a lot
of it is just coming
back to having this mindset of
making sure that we're keeping
focused on the end goal that
we're looking for, and not
necessarily say, hey,
data team, can you
go pull this data for us?
Like, the gut reaction is, sure,
I can easily do that for you.
But like, what's the intent
of the question that you're
trying to solve or the problem
that you're trying to solve?
And let us think a
bit more holistically
and as a partnership
so that we can
think to try to drive a bit
more solutioning and decisioning
behind that because
we as data science
and analytics already
have that mindset
and know a bit more
of what data can do.
The stakeholders,
even though they do--
they are very focused
in, like, having
data drive their organization,
they don't necessarily
know what data can do.
They know how they would
want to analyze data,
but it's not necessarily
the right way.
So, to kind of come back
to your question, Rachel,
about a specific instance, we
received one question early
on from one of our
stakeholders when I came here,
and it was, hey, can you go
do a segmentation for us,
or can you build
some clusters for us?
And when it's like--
I mean, yeah, we could.
Like, what are the
hypotheses that you have
that you're trying to solve?
What is the business problem
you're trying to solve?
And I didn't really
have the context
of the business at the
time because I was only
about a month in.
But it really comes
back to trying
to identify what is it you're
trying to solve out of this.
If I deliver some
segments for you,
how are you going to use
that to drive decisions?
Are you going to
have personalization?
Is it going to change
your audience strategy?
Is it going to allow us
to do some type of testing
to make sure they're relevant?
So I think just continuing
to have those conversations
with stakeholders allows it to
be a bit more focused and less
prescriptive from their
part and more so, like,
thinking a bit more generally
about what can be done.
We're actually just talking
about that a bit internally
this week and thinking
about the problem
first before we start
jumping into all
these different solutions.
But part of that was also,
like, getting everybody
to agree on what the problem is.
Is that something you have
to do across all teams?
JOSH KING: Yeah, it's definitely
something we have to do,
and I think it's a bit
easier when you take it back
in terms of
prioritization because we
kind of as a company what our
goal is over the next five
years.
And we all-- as we're doing
our own objective setting,
we're making sure that they
kind of align up to that.
So if we receive
a question about,
hey, you can we do
this analysis to see
what's going to happen
here, whether that's
like an analysis for which
marketing campaign worked
better or which specific
channel on a specific campaign
drove the most xyz
aspect within our brand,
it kind of comes down to how
is this going to help us align
towards us reaching our
goal because there's
a significant
amount of questions
that we ourselves are
asking ourselves, that
are our marketing
team is asking,
that our product team is asking,
our operations team is asking.
And there's a lot more
questions than there
are resources within the team.
So it really comes
down to having
a very level head in terms of
prioritization to make sure
that we're focused on
the right problems.
And then if we
can't align on there
being a problem
in itself, then I
think that's one of those
general things where it's
let's kind of think through
what are some of our hypotheses
and then continue to refine
a bit about what it is we're
trying to get out of this.
Sometimes, that's just relevant
for an exploration exercise
to say, do we really
have a problem,
or do we kind of
just think there is/
Thank you.
Ahnas, I see you
have your hand raise.
Do you want to jump in here?
Sure.
Josh, so I want to
pick your brain on--
I'm assuming that your company
does use social media data
to find prospective customers.
And I'm just curious of--
obviously, whatever you
can share-- if you use R,
if you use any other
tools in that process,
whether to feed it
into a model or--
I don't know.
That's a personal
interest of mine,
leveraging social media data and
incorporating it into a model.
JOSH KING: Yeah,
so I think there's
a couple of different
aspects there.
One is generally, within the
newer privacy constraints,
it's hard to do any type of
user level analysis where
you necessarily know
specifically, especially
within social media, any
actions that a user is taking
and then align--
especially if you
want to align that
to something that's
happening within our platform.
So that's one aspect.
As an aside, I'm somewhat
generally for sharing my data
because as a data scientist
and as a marketing focus data
scientist, I'd
prefer to have ads
that are 100% relevant to me
so that I don't have to go
searching for something else.
I just like-- every single ad
that I receive is something
that I want or would need.
So, that's an aside.
The other aspect there
is getting into, like,
using social media data.
So, one specific aspect that
you could utilize there,
and this is, like, under the
assumption that maybe you're
working for a brand or you
have some means of aligning
on driving relevant people to
whatever platform you may have,
is by using signals that
you can send back to-- so,
things like Google or
Facebook-- that allow them
on their end to do some type
of lookalike audience building
where it's like, hey,
I've received these 1,000
people from your
platform, and here's
the click that they
came into our site on.
I don't necessarily
know who they are.
But I can say, like,
this is the value that we
see based on some
predictive model we've built
and then send that value back
to those social media channels
so that they can
therefore say, OK,
I know how much you
spend on this click.
I know the value that
you receive from it.
Now I can help optimize
the return on that
spend that you're giving us send
more relevant customers back
And they can do that via
lookalike audience modeling.
Cool.
Thank you.
JOSH KING: Yeah, sure.
There was actually a follow up
question that was asked-- well,
maybe not a follow up.
It was asked
anonymously earlier,
but have the recent privacy
changes and browsers affected
your MTA modeling
if you do this,
and I might need to
know what MTA is,
and push your
efforts towards MMM?
JOSH KING: Yeah, so, MTA stands
for multitouch attribution--
RACHEL DEMPSEY: OK.
--which is a means of
aligning all of the marketing
touchpoints that a user could
have before they make some
action or they don't
make an action.
And so, yes, definitely
privacy constraints
are a significant blocker there.
Even thinking back to, like,
2018 when we were doing this
at Domino's, there was
a significant blocker
within the social media
channels specifically
that are very walled gardens.
You can't align on
an impression level
basis who's seeing your ads.
So it's definitely
a challenge there.
One way that we're
trying to work around
that is by, rather
than building out
peer what I would call
MTA, which is generally
using some type of Markov
chain model, that is impression
level, that we're building out
more of a click-based MTA which
aligns for a specific user.
Again, this kind of comes down
to our identity resolution
and how well we can
align any specific click
to any specific individual.
For any of the clicks
that they're making,
what is the
allocation that we may
give to each of the marketing
touchpoints that they have
before they make some action?
So, that allows us to get
a bit more perspective
into some what you may
call supporting marketing
channels rather than, say, the
last click before an action
happens or the first click
before an action happens.
So you can kind of consider some
different weighting scenarios
there that may do it.
The other aspect there
was getting into the MMM,
and this is kind of, like I'd
say, over the last four or five
years, there's been a bit
of a resurgence in MMM
where prior to that, everybody
was saying, oh, MMM is dead.
It's such an archaic
method that's
being utilized to
optimize marketing spend.
And yeah, it was
developed in the '60s,
but it's still highly
relevant, especially
now as privacy concerns
are coming out,
especially with in Europe, where
privacy laws are already well
ahead what they are in the US.
So, the benefit to an MMM
is that it doesn't require
user level data to do this.
It's very looking at it from
an econometrics perspective
and building out a model
that can be very focused
across the entirety and not just
within digital channels-- also
within TV and terrestrial
radio and billboards--
to get a read into how all the
marketing channels kind of work
together.
Thank you.
Martin, I see you
have your hand raised.
Nice to see you.
Nice to see you, Rachel.
Hi, I'm Martin.
I am the CMO at Union.ai.
We do data, and
ML orchestrators.
I used to work for RStudio,
So I know some people here.
So, I think this is
super interesting.
I asked the last
question [INAUDIBLE]
MTA versus [INAUDIBLE] Markov
chain-based MTAs and so on so.
But I see also the resurgence of
MMM, but it has issues, right?
I mean, if you have
time series that
are short or spasticity
of observations,
it's not going to be good.
So, how do you overcome that?
Yeah, that's definitely a
challenge have to kind of work
with.
One potential method
which, like, granted,
it's not necessarily going
to always be relevant.
But if you're able to go
further in granularity,
then that can start to improve
some of the sample sizes
you have available in
order to build out a model
and allows you to do a bit
more robust techniques.
So right now, the model
that we're building is, one,
it's using open source framework
from Facebook called Robin,
which is pretty powerful.
And it's built in R, and
it's pretty out of the box
capable of doing
pretty robust MMMs.
Next steps beyond that
are getting into more--
when you think of,
like, rigorously
focused ones, getting into
hierarchical time series,
using Bayesian
methods, which, there's
a package in R
called RStan, which
uses the Stan framework to
get into that Bayesian level.
That's what we used at Domino's.
And within that, as you
continue to increase
the levels of granularity,
you can use the posterior
distribution from one model
to inform the priors getting
into another one, which
allows you to account
for some of that
sparsity you may have
just by getting through there.
Another means is by if you
don't want to go further
in granularity, you can
actually do the opposite
and start to aggregate some
of those marketing channels
that may be relevant from
a consumer's perspective.
So, one of the considerations
we made with the current model
that we're focusing
on at TKWW is
by aggregating
Pinterest and Instagram,
which, like, they're completely
different marketing channels.
And they have-- Meta
and Pinterest have
no combination to each other.
But from a consumer
perspective, when
they're considering
wedding planning,
they're both used as a means
of getting visual inspiration
for planning their wedding
and seeing photos that
are relevant to search for.
So it makes sense to aggregate
both of those together because
of the sparsity that we had
in some of those channels,
which allows us to get a good
insight to say we may not
be able to see what
Pinterest is doing
or what Instagram
is doing in a silo,
but we can say for
visual inspiration,
it has this return
on our ad spend.
And then as we get into
further models later on,
then you can get into
that hierarchical analysis
where are you able
to then parse down
what's actually happening
within each of those channels
specifically.
Thanks.
Caitlin, I see you had a
question in the chat a bit
earlier too if you
want to jump in next.
And I can get started
with the question,
but it was, how
do you collaborate
between R and Python?
Are these separate teams?
They're not separate teams.
It kind of depends on what
people are used to using,
and that's definitely a struggle
to consider when you want
to do quality assurance on the
code basis that's being written
if one of the data scientists
is an expert in the problem
that you're trying to solve or
has some knowledge about it,
but they know Python, and I'm
coding in R. Then definitely
becomes a challenge.
We're currently working on
building out our overall data
roadmap for our
department on, like,
what is the appropriate
means and scenario here
for getting it and
being able to have
these cross-code capabilities.
I think one of the
challenges there is again,
if you're focused on
a specific language,
you're not necessarily
focused on the problem
itself, which you can also
relate to if you're focused on,
hey, I just found this
new novel technique,
let me see how I can
pigeonhole it into the problem
that I have, then you're not
really focused on the problem
because that may
not be as relevant.
So I think one of
the areas to do
is just have some
means of identifying
who would be relevant to
look at your codebase,
even if they're not
necessarily on the same team.
I've been at some
companies in the past that
were significant in size where
there was, like, basically
an internal R user group and
an internal Python user group,
which allows for a lot of that
language-specific collaboration
and discussions.
Thank you.
One other anonymous
question that came in
is, what are the
skills and tools
that you're looking for in
the senior data science role?
Is MM mandatory
for this profile,
and also how could somebody
reach out to you for this role?
So, I'm pretty
active on LinkedIn.
So, definitely feel free
to reach out to me there.
And the role that
I'm hiring for right
now is I'm actually
looking for--
I'm not looking for
MMM experience at all.
So I have a data scientist
that has a lot of fantastic MMM
experience.
I also have a lot of
experience in that myself.
So the person that
we're looking for.
Now is a bit more of
a generalized data
scientist, thinking through
predictive modeling.
If you have some experience
in LTB or churn modeling,
that's definitely a benefit,
as our focus is on LTD.
I think churn is a little
less relevant just because
of like how I was framing
earlier about what
our couples are going through.
But if you have
experience in that,
it's definitely a benefit.
Thank you.
Greg, I see you just put
a question in the chat.
You want to jump in and--
I always forget to say
this, but if anyone
wants to introduce
themselves as well too,
I'll add that in there.
Hey, sure, yeah.
I can go ahead.
So, my name is Greg Shick.
I'm director of analytics
for Charles Schwab covering
asset risk management.
And Josh, I just picked up
on a keyword you said there.
It was your data and
analytics roadmap.
And we kind of have
a similar process.
We manage two separate roadmaps.
And I'm just wondering how
logistically you manage that.
What goes into creating that?
How far out do you go?
How far out do you try to plan?
Does it cover all
types of data works,
or is it just more like
a data science roadmap,
or do you include data
engineering projects, BI,
ad hoc things?
So, if you could speak
a little bit about that.
Sure.
Yeah, so I'm actually
in the midst right now--
as in, like, the hour
before this meeting--
I was doing this-- on
getting a bit more refinement
on my roadmap because we're
having a data heads offsite
next week in New York to kind
of talk through holistically
about each of our pillars as
well as the overall data org.
So it's top of mind for me, so
pretty relevant timing there.
So, one of the things
I like to come back to
is the CTO at my
last company, he
had this really good
framework for kind
of thinking through
this, and it's
to break it out into your
mission, your vision,
your maturity model,
and your strategy.
And that kind of
allows a bit-- and so
if you want to look it up, he
has a great article on medium.
His name is Dave Kaplan, and he
has some good articles on that.
But if you search for those
keywords and Dave Kaplan,
there's a really
great posting on it.
This kind of gets
into a good framework
for building out and
identifying, like,
what are the different aspects
of a strategy that you should
consider and having a
clear alignment for what
that will look like.
And generally, a mission
is like a single sentence
for why your team or your
department or your company
exists.
And your vision is what does
it mean to succeed within that.
So, like, if I'm thinking
through marketing DSNA,
I'm thinking through,
like, what does it
mean to have a best in
class marketing data
science organization, like,
across relevant brands?
And then your maturity model
is, where are you along
that map from very basic early
foundational building into I
am best in class?
And then your
strategy is how you
get from where you
are now to where
you want to be in your vision.
So, this really aligns
a good framework
for what it is that
you're building out.
And to the other part
of your question,
like, does it cover
all data work?
So, I have data scientists and
analytics that report into me,
but there's also
some of a dotted line
from all of our
data engineers that
focus on marketing problems.
So that can include BI.
That can include data
operations, data warehouse,
tracking architecture.
And as we're thinking through a
bit more holistically in terms
of all of our data functions
that are supporting marketing,
I identify, like,
what do we need
to drive decision making for our
marketing organization and not
only, like, how does data
science and analytics fit
into that, but, like, what
is the infrastructure we need
from a data engineering
perspective that would allow us
and enable us to be
able to do this work
so that it's not just
focus on that one?
But then, yes, it's
not necessarily
my vision or my strategy
that will get us there
but working really closely
with our head of data
platform so that my
vision and his vision
are really aligned
together and thinking
through a bit more holistically
as we're building that out.
And I think the other question
was, like, how long is it?
So, my current focus
is on building out
a one year, a three year,
and a five year roadmap
to really have some intermediate
stages along the way
that we're getting towards.
Got you.
That's impressive.
We're working on the
one to three year.
We haven't gotten to
the five year yet.
But that's pretty cool.
I think it's a bit of a
struggle because especially
within data science, like, it's
so rapidly evolving that it's
hard to think
through what's even
going to be the atmosphere
and the environment in five
years from now.
Yeah, absolutely.
The other struggle
we seem to see
is the need for some of the
foundational data engineering
work to come first to enable
some of those capabilities,
right?
We've got a million requests
to add ChatGPT to something,
and we're like, well, we need to
build some data infrastructure
first.
So, it's not as an
easy sell, I think,
to do that foundational first.
So, cool.
I appreciate that.
Yeah, it's definitely-- it's
a bit challenging in terms
of orchestration to make sure
that all those pieces kind
of fit together.
So, as I build out
my roadmap there
are some things
that can be done now
based on the
infrastructure we have
and some things
that, like, yeah,
it'd be great to do it now.
But really, this would need
to be on the immediate roadmap
for data engineering
to build out
what we need in order for us to
do that even a year from now.
Absolutely.
Thanks.
Thank you.
Curtis, I know you had a
question a bit earlier to
if you want to jump in next.
Yeah, I just had kind
of a methodology question.
I was kind of curious what
kind of randomized control
experiments you
guys are running,
if you could talk about
that, and particularly
how you integrate that into your
analytics pipelines, marketing
strategy.
You talked a lot about
fomenting empiricism.
And I've heard a lot of things,
of kind of prediction models.
But I was just kind of
curious about the experiments
you might run that
sort of thing.
I haven't heard you
talk about that yet.
Yeah, so within marketing,
the experimentation
is really being done somewhat
siloed within the marketing
channels currently.
And Facebook or Google, they
have their own abilities
to do a lot of testing.
We can do some analysis on the
back end to do more down funnel
experiments-- excuse me--
North Carolina pollen.
So, we're getting into now too--
and this is one of the things on
like the next couple of roadmap
is-- to build out more of
a geo-based experimentation
framework, which allows-- it's
not randomized but allows us
to do have a good
amount of insight
to for a specific geography
or a sub-geography
and then have a relevant
control set to compare against.
I'd say a lot of those--
RCT is happening
within our product side
and getting through
people who are actually
within our platform
to try to drive
a lot of that experimentation
via A/B testing.
And it's not even necessarily
A/B testing-- like,
multivariate testing as well--
to really drive a lot of
that personalization, what
works well as we're making
changes to the website.
Thank you.
I know a bit earlier,
you talked about how
you work across, like,
cross-departmental
partnerships.
And a lot of times,
we'll talk about how
you build relationships across
the company in this data
science hangout format.
And I'm just curious what
that looks like [INAUDIBLE]..
Yeah, so I try to make
a specific intent to--
especially since, as I was going
through my first six months,
really building out a lot of the
relationships with the people
that I would be working with
or, like, partnering generally
close with.
And a lot of that is just,
like, communicating on Slack
to say like, hey,
what's going on
or having regular touch
bases in one on ones.
There's also-- if you consider
within whatever organization
you're in, if there's
ever, like, lunch
and learns or any aspect to
hear from others' perspective,
go to those and ask questions.
I think that's one way just to
kind of get out there and start
to build some of
those relationships
is by just being there
and hearing other people's
perspectives.
And if they ask, do
you have any questions,
like, try to have
some type of question
that you're able to ask because
I think that's just a good way
to try to get your voice
heard and start to build
a lot of that relationship.
Absolutely.
Thank you.
Jonathan, I see you asked the
question, and there's a star.
So I'll read it.
So, the question was, does
your team use omnichannel data
for driving revenue and solving
problems within your teams?
If so, then what
is a typical issue
faced in your area and your
approach to problem solving?
Yeah, so we
definitely are focused
on omnichannel experiences
and try to make sure
that any marketing experience
that somebody is getting
is relevant across any marketing
touchpoint that they receive.
So, a primary focus
that we're utilizing
to do that is via the CDP,
or Customer Data Platform,
which allows us to
orchestrate journeys
to make sure that
we're sending content
relevant to the experience
that somebody has had
within our platform and what
they're interested in based
on what keywords
they're searching for
or something like that to make
sure that if they're getting
an ad on Google and an ad
on Facebook that the copy is
relevant to them, and
it's relevant to whatever
it is that they're doing.
So that CDP has really
been a significant aspect
to allowing us to get into a
lot more personalization based
on specific events
that are actually
happening within our website.
And just to double check, CDP,
that's Customer Data Profile?
Customer Data Platform.
RACHEL DEMPSEY: Or platform.
OK.
So it's like a
singular location
to store profiling variables
about customers that you know
as well as all of the
actions that are actually
happening within your website.
And you can build filters
and do custom SQL traits
and really get a good
perspective about how people
are interacting and then
build custom journeys
based on how those interactions
are actually happening.
Cool.
Thank you.
There is an anonymous question.
I just had to actually
Google this real quick,
but what has your company done
with generative AI if anything?
So, nothing yet.
That is something that we
are considering getting into.
This is an idea that
I had early on that I
kind of pitched to
our product side.
If we have, say, a woman
shopping for wedding dresses,
and she has a photo
of herself, can we
have, within our
product, the ability
to allow her to completely
visualize herself
in 10 different wedding dresses?
Or if somebody has
a specific color
profile that they want to have
and see how flowers would be
and also have
something else, like,
allow it to do some
of this color picking
across different palettes
to allow a very personalized
wedding planning experience?
So it's definitely something
that's on our radar
as we're trying to
keep up with a lot
of the ever-evolving
trends but nothing
that we're currently
actively using.
It's making me think of when
you buy something on Wayfair,
and you can take a
picture of your house
and see what the
furniture looks like.
Exactly.
Let me just double check here.
I haven't given any of
the anonymous questions.
But I think, Katherine, you had
another question in the chat
too if you want to jump in.
KATHERINE GERTON: Yeah, and
it may be a little charged
for this format.
So, feel free to cage
however you'd like.
But just curious with how
many aspects of weddings
are now legally and
politically socially complex,
what sort of are your guys'
marketing and engagement teams
doing maybe in political
action or other sorts
of social community activities
using some of the data
that you collect?
Yeah, that's a
really great question.
So, I don't necessarily know
about utilizing any of the data
that we collect,
but we definitely,
as a company and
our CEO himself,
have come out in our support
of gay marriage and making sure
that everybody is
feeling inclusive.
So, like, as a
couple of years ago,
there was a lot of that
discussion and along
the political
atmosphere, like, there's
a lot of statements
coming from our company.
So, I don't know that we're
necessarily utilizing any data.
We do have some
diversity filters that
are able to be utilized within
this, within our platform
to say like, hey, if
I'm an LGBTQ couple
and I want to make sure that
I'm supporting an LGBTQ vendor,
then I can filter
on that one just
to kind of keep like for like
and look for those focus areas.
But we're not necessarily
doing anything
in terms of an analysis or
data science perspective
to share anything out there.
I think it could be a pretty
good idea for some type of data
journalism within some
of our editorial content
to look at the different trends
that are happening there,
though.
KATHERINE GERTON:
Yeah, I actually
am not a member of
the LGBT community,
but I was getting
married in Texas,
and it was important
to me to find
an officiant who didn't say no
LGBT weddings on their website.
And that kind of thing
can be really important
and just like a really powerful,
simple filter that people want.
Or I guess some people want to
filter the other way as well.
So--
Thank you.
A question that I
always like to ask Josh
is, is there a piece
of career advice
that you've ever received
or maybe that you've
given that stands out to you?
Ooh, that's a good one.
Well, I kind of actually
already used one of them,
which was if you're in
a meeting and you're
asked if you have any
questions, then ask a question.
But I also--
I feel like I can't
repurpose that one,
but maybe I could punt
and say that I would.
But I think there
is something that's
somewhat relevant to that even
though it's not necessarily
a piece of advice but
just a general mannerism.
If you're giving a
presentation and you get to end
and you say, do you
have any questions,
it's much easier to get
some engagement from others
if you reframe that to say,
what questions do you have?
I think, like, generally,
and I've seen this also
from experience-- granted,
I didn't set it up
as an A/B test.
But you get a lot more
relevance coming out of it
and engagement if you say,
what questions do you have,
and people are more
likely to do that.
Also, if you ask
somebody what questions
do you have or do you
have any questions,
count to 17 in your head.
It's not like 1, 2, 3, 4.
It's like 1, 2, 3, 4,
5, 6, getting to 17.
And that pause is
sufficient enough
to allow somebody to kind of
wrap their thoughts together
and build out something
so that they can actually
have something ready for you.
A lot of times, somebody will
say, do you have any questions?
OK, good, and then
see you later.
But actually having that
specific pause in there
and actually doing that
mental counting in your head
allows for a decent amount of
time to actually get there.
The thought of waiting for
17 seconds there just gave me
a little bit of anxiety, but--
I've called it
out specifically--
Are there any questions?
Yeah, I've called that
out specifically to my team
so that if they feel a
very long pause from me,
that's exactly what
I'm doing because I
heard this piece of
advice at one point.
And so it's not that I'm just,
like, sitting there waiting--
I'm waiting indefinitely.
It's just I have
this specific pause.
KATHERINE GERTON: Yeah, and with
Zoom, it's not like, oh, maybe
he's having audio difficulty.
RACHEL DEMPSEY: Right.
Exactly.
So, actually, are
there any questions
that I have missed in
the Zoom chat here?
Feel free to just raise your
hand if there's something
that you want to bring to the
top or something we've missed.
I actually did just see
one come in on Slido
right now that was
what important roles
or opportunities have you taken
throughout your career that has
helped shape who you are today.
Oh, that's a really
great question.
So I think there was one.
So I used to work at Domino's,
and I was promoted to Director,
and then I think, like,
six months later--
so, my wife was a professor
at the University of Michigan
at that point.
But we're both
from the Carolinas.
And Duke University
reached out to her
and ended up offering
her a position.
And so we were moving
back to the Carolinas
to be closer to family.
And then I wasn't really
finding the right job
in an industry that I
felt really strong about.
But I had-- as I was just kind
of talking to people that I was
meeting through my wife's
academic relationships,
I met these--
at Duke, they had a
new program called
Master and Interdisciplinary
Data Science.
And within that one, I really
loved kind of the framing
that they were doing.
And they were
looking for somebody
who had a lot of
industry experience
to come in and be
faculty to not just talk
about the theoretics behind the
machine learning applications
that are happening, which,
like, at Duke, there's
a lot of amazing professors that
can help drive a lot of that,
but they're looking for somebody
that had a lot of that softer
skill aspect that you can
find with a strong data
scientist, the work
through project management
and build relationships
and ask the right questions
and effective
storytelling, et cetera.
So, because I wasn't finding
the right job in industry,
I wanted to go with that one.
And sadly, my wife was like, oh,
you're going to hate academia.
It's not like working
in an industry.
I'm like, no, no, it's
going to be great.
And then I got in there, and
it was very changing for me.
I saw a lot of
different perspectives
and was able to get a lot of
different project experience
as I was doing that.
I did find pretty quickly that
academia is just not for me,
but like I still feel like
it was something that really
changed me for the
better as I was working
with a lot of these grad
students that were really early
on in building their
career and seeing
a lot of these different
projects that were being worked
on.
Thank you.
I do see one other question that
came in the chat from Jonathan,
and Jonathan said,
for someone that's
new to the field of data
science and has experience using
R and Python with banking, what
are helpful resources, books,
or communities you
recommend that could support
with that transition
to data science?
Yeah, so my
master's was actually
in computational finance.
So it's something that I have
had a bit of focus on it,
but a lot of it wasn't,
like, the actual mathematics
side-- like, building out some
pretty intense math theorems
for them and stuff like that.
But one of the books that
I go to even still now is--
and I can follow up after
and send this to you.
But it's like a an advanced
econometrics using R book.
And I think that's one
that I go to a lot,
and econometrics is very
heavily used within finance.
That's getting into a lot of the
different types of time series
analyses.
I wouldn't have as
much recommendations
if you're trying to get
into algorithmic trading.
I had a class in that
one, but it wasn't
highly interesting to me.
It's an amazingly
interesting subject but not
one of those ones
that I'm an expert in.
Thank you very much.
I was just asking in the chat
if anybody can find that book,
feel free to put it
there in the chat.
I was trying to do
Google at the same time.
Hey, Trevor.
I see your hand.
--Advanced Micro Econometrics
or something like that,
and it was all in R.
Awesome.
Hey, Trevor I see
your hand raised.
Do you want to
jump in here next?
TREVOR: Yeah.
Hi, Rachel, Hi, everyone.
Hi, Josh.
So, my question-- I'd made a
statement before in the chat,
but I'm turning it
into a question, right?
So, last week, I was asking
about the impact of AI
on data science, right?
So I'm continuing in that vein
where, do you think, Josh--
and it's just your opinion.
Given the advance of
AI, and we clearly
see AI is making great strides
in terms of writing codes,
right?
Writing code.
Do you think that
most for our time
will be spent more
on qualitative things
such as assisting stakeholders
in defining the problem as
opposed to thinking about
the latest way to code
or thinking about the
latest algorithm or anything
like that?
Do you see, like, a
shift or a balance
or a shift in terms of
where we spend our time
as data scientists?
Yeah, that's a really
engaging question.
I think there's a lot
of hot takes on that.
I think for the immediate
future, if nothing else,
it's going to allow data
scientists to probably code
a bit more efficiently.
I think a significant
challenge--
and, like, I haven't asked,
like, ChatGPT to go in
and build something, write
a piece of code for me.
I think my wife is
done this, which
maybe alleviates my requirement
to utilize helper for her.
But along those
lines, I think it's
going to allow data scientists
to be more efficient as they're
coding.
I'd say it's probably
like five to seven years
until I can actually do
anything substantially
relevant to consider, like,
data scientists are only working
on framing problems in a way
that AI can interpret them
and being able to be embedded on
top of Your snowflake warehouse
so that you can
just ask a question,
and then it'll go through
and build in a model.
I think we're a long
way away from that.
TREVOR: OK, thanks.
It's amazing to think about.
But from my own
career perspective,
I hope we don't get
there anytime soon.
[LAUGHTER]
So, random question that
just came to mind, but like,
we talked about
omnichannel marketing
and different marketing
analysis that you do.
But I'm curious if
there's a company
that you think is doing a
really good job at this that is
marketing to you individually.
Yeah, so I received an
ad, an email, a couple
of days ago from Verizon.
And I just-- generally, I
pay no attention to them.
And so I utilize
Verizon as my service.
But I clicked on the link.
And then immediately
after, I saw,
when I was watching the
Hurricanes game last night,
that there were several ads
that were all focused on Verizon
and then received another one
today as I was on my computer.
It's like, their omnichannel
experience is top notch and,
like, able to be
connected across all
of these different devices.
So that's just one
that's, like, top of mind
as I've been noticing
over the past couple days.
Well, thank you.
I know we're getting to
the end of the time here,
but I want to make
sure that I share
the roles that you have open
and just put those into the chat
here.
I found the one--
so I think I have the one for
senior data scientist, which
is here on LinkedIn.
Yeah, so we shared--
RACHEL DEMPSEY: But if you
have a general Careers page,
I should probably go to that.
I think I might actually have
that up somewhere because I
was looking at them earlier
to make sure I had all of them
right.
I'm not seeing it.
I have too many
tabs open right now,
but I can put it with
the recording too.
JOSH KING: Yes, OK.
And I'm sure we can
navigate to the Careers page.
Yeah, I'll follow up
with you after that one.
But if you go through
theknotwww.com, that's
our Careers pages, and
then search for data,
we have two open senior
data scientist positions.
One is based out of Spain,
one is remote anywhere
in the US, which is
the one on my team.
We have a product data
science manager position
that's remote open
anywhere in the US
and then also a data science
director position that
is based out of Barcelona.
Perfect.
Well, thank you so much,
Josh, for joining us today
and sharing your experience.
Thank you all for all
the great questions.